the thought is that these if something
comes along and it kills all of the non
resistant cells all the fast cells then
the slow cells can repopulate that
population whereas if you had no slow
cells the population as a whole would be
able to grow a little tiny bit faster in
the absence of any bad things happening
in the absence of stress but if some
stress come went long it would kill off
the whole population it would kill off
everyone and then you have zero cells
entire evolutionarily dead yeah if I all
just want to understand things I want to
understand how cells work they want to
understand why we look and behave the
way they do and we want to understand
things too but we want to do so in in a
quantitative manner that I can write
down my predictions for the future and
see if they come true or not if I have a
population of a million cells and I give
them some drug that kills 99% of them I
want to be able to tell you before
giving them the drug which cells will
survive in which cells will die if if we
can do that then we can really
understand the system know someone's
opinion me contradict yours boy my
friend Alan it's all about your
perspective who are we in what is the
nature of this reality
[Music]
Nihao everybody welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sathyan we are still
in the beautiful Beijing China we are at
Peking University School of Life
Sciences we are now going to be talking
about mechanistic prediction in biology
we have dr. Lucas Kerry joining us on
the show Heather this oh thank you so
much for coming on the show really
appreciate it
love your work it was so cool getting to
know it deeper and hanging out a bit
more last night talking about all our
cool ideas and stuff like that it was
great I'm so pumped for this show for
those who don't know Lucas's background
he's the p.i principal investigator of
the Kari lab at Peking University Centre
for quantitative biology his lab is
focused on understanding and predicting
how individual cells and populations
behave and you can find his links in the
bio below to the Kerry lab as well as
his Twitter profile all right Lucas
let's start things off with one of our
favorite questions to ask our guests
what are your thoughts on a direction of
our world I think it you know generally
it's getting better it you know the rate
of change is decreasing these days I
think but I'm confident that this is
temporary I certainly hope that this is
temporary and that you know relations
between China and the US will get better
that yeah so I'm not worried and for the
long term yeah that's why we're here
we're here to hopefully open up more
friendship and collaboration and global
cohesion between the US China and the
other countries in the world and what
would you say about the rate of change
because so many people come on the show
and they talk about oh my gosh so rate
of change is increasing there's so many
exponential technologies unleashing into
the world and it's being democratized so
where do you see it actually slowing
down well I see I see more protectionism
coming in in the US we see this with a
decreased immigration with making weird
it more difficult for foreigners to get
green cards and to convert their PhD
that they get in the u.s. into a job and
family in the u.s. I see this also in
China that it's you know more difficult
than it was three years ago five years
ago - for foreigners to use like payment
systems and rent bicycles and things
like this in China and so this this is I
think slow exam oh okay think I see so
it's like so there's like a the eat
although the exponential technologies
are continuing to boom there's still
some sort of like a slowdown of like
there's some sort of conservatism it's
still happening at the same time and I
think that immigration in all directions
is one of the things that gives you
technological development right a lot of
the founders of major companies in the
US are immigrants Arizona immigrants and
so the if we want the technological the
rate of technological progress to
continue to increase as fast as a
husband the world needs to remain more
open in my opinion yeah yeah I was
mentioning that so many times now it's
like I can't email some of the picking
university professors because my Gmail
or Yahoo emails land in their spam boxes
I can't get a WeChat payer and Holly pay
here because I don't have a Chinese bank
account I can't link my visa to it so
people look at me like why you giving me
this archaic cash to scan my QR code
yeah so it'll be interesting to see how
much easier it is like it took a long
time to get a visa to come to China it's
a quite a long and tedious and multi-day
process and so you wonder what could be
the future of being able to transit
between country safely vetted in a
vetted way what could be so easy as to
just have money not need conversions and
all this type of stuff but it's
interesting the cryptocurrency
revolution where that could lead us and
to make it easy for people to be able to
create a creatively collaborate across
the world like if you want founders of
the most massive companies in the world
to continue for that process continue
happening making it easier for people to
be creative is a core aspect of that
Lucas who were you growing up it was
Woodstock in New York where you're born
and then you went to Stony Brook but how
did you get interested in genetics and
in science when you were a kid so I
don't know the remember the exact moment
but the sort of milestone is in fifth
grade I did a genetics project for the
science fair where I did crosses of
hamsters and so we ended up with 34
hamsters and in my house the offspring
of the parents that I was doing the
cross with and my you know hypotheses so
we got more offspring though that were
white and we're golden would look more
like the female than the male and my
hypothesis was that they spend more time
in their mother and therefore they have
more maternal traits so well I was
completely wrong but that was kind of
the first memory kind of created by my
parents keeping the poster so I don't
know how much I really remember and how
much I seem to remember from the poster
but definitely I was doing science then
doing genetics then cool cool and I love
hearing about the stories like that it
makes me want to enable more children
around the world to have access to
science projects like that and mentors
that can help them with that because
those moments are so pivotal in their
picking up what you care about I can
also just like 34 hamsters in the house
like yeah yeah the young scientist and
then now teach us about the trajectory
to Stony Brook Brook and through Stony
Brook which is on Long Iowa yeah on the
northern part of Long Island
yeah yeah North Shore yeah so Stony
Brook was great I got there I had done
some research in in biology and also in
computer science as an undergraduate and
so I started my PhD and I ended up just
kind of hanging out with the guy who was
gonna become my PhD advisor at the first
year PhD students like retreat this was
when alcohol restrictions were a little
bit looser in the US and
Stoneybrook would take all the PhD
students out to a hotel and kind of
farther east so Hmong island and get all
the students and professors drunk for
the weekend and get some mingling and so
I thought it was great and so I started
talking to this guy who I had no idea
who he was and then ended up doing my
PhD with him so we worked on on cell
cycle control so yeast cells and also
mammalian cells don't divide into from
one cell into two cells until they've
reached some volume and so they have
some way of set a single cell has some
way of sensing how big it is and we
don't know how that is like a cell
doesn't have a ruler that it kind of
became yeah so what is it measuring
exactly is a measuring diameter is a
measuring volume isn't measuring the
amount of protein and so I spent my PhD
trying to work on what do cells actually
measure to know how big their whoa and
what did you find out so we found out
that founded a couple of things it's a
long time ago some people say that like
damn what was it yeah so one of the
things we found out is that the so we're
basically we're looking for something
that's increasing all cells growing in
size and you if you had a ruler that
ruler might remain constant as the cell
grows in size and so one thing that
remains constant so yeast cells in
particular and also mammalian cells
this measurement happens before cells
replicate their DNA so while they have
just a single copy of their genome and
what we call g1 before DNA replication
and what remains constant is the amount
of DNA and what increases is the amount
of everything else inside the cell as it
grows bigger and so what we found was
that the amount of these unstable
activators that promote progression into
S phase and through the cell cycle they
increase very quickly through this
period but the number of binding sites
for them in the genome of course remains
constant because the DNA replication is
not occurring and that if we increase
the number of binding sites we delay
progression through the cell cycle if we
decrease the number of binding sites we
promote progression through the cell
cycle and so it seems to be this that is
the
ruler is kind of the ratio between the
number of these protein molecules inside
the cell and the number of physical
binding sites for them in the genome
whoa okay okay so there's a quantitative
mechanistic code to the cell when it
decides to divide yeah and it has to do
with the amount of proteins that are
inside of the cell yeah and and then two
binding sites on the DNA yes okay and as
those get to a certain threshold then it
can divide exactly so you can imagine
there's some constant number of binding
sites and then the number of proteins
are increasing
mm-hm and then eventually they reach
some kind of ratio threshold interest
and then this how can this cell can
divide and be able to sustain yeah and
then okay interesting so that could be
then that moment where it's like okay
there's enough proteins there's a
certain amount of binding sites what if
we divide now we'll be able to sustain
we'll be able to live and that's yeah my
goodness when we were talking about
stuff like this last night we were just
going off about how there's just so much
quantitative mechanisms in biology and
where you are basically like just diving
deep into the how these things are
actually codified and how we can explain
them and gain insights from them and
it's cool that you ended up actually
starting to do that so early and you're
even in your PhD work okay so then this
was cool the Weizmann Institute in
Israel so this is where you did your
postdoc yeah okay what were you doing
there and what is that Institute about
all right so vitamin is I think it's a
smallish Research Institute there's
maybe a thousand people or so it's about
20 minutes outside of Tel Aviv and it is
in my opinion it's one of the most
creative places for science in the world
so it's a little bit outside of
mainstream right you too long flight to
get there it's not in Europe it's not in
the US it's a little bit isolated
and it gives it I think a sense of
freedom so science there's is very good
very high level but also they like to do
things a little bit off the beaten path
scientifically and so there's a lot of
really fantastic really creative
scientists there there isn't the sort of
money to do let's sequence a hundred
thousand people or this sort of science
that is interesting but it's just driven
by infinite sums of money that there are
at some places in the US for example and
so they asked and say okay with plenty
of resources but not those kinds of
resources what is the coolest stuff that
we can do and the so I was in the
computer science department but I was
doing biology and we were working on the
group I was working in of Professor
Aaron Segal was working on gene
expression so how many how does the cell
control how many molecules of mRNA how
many molecules of protein are produced
and how is that information encoded in
the genome of that cell so right so Eric
Lander who led the human genome
sequencing has this great quote about
the human genome bought the book
difficult to read and in Aaron's lab we
were trying to understand how to how
does this he'll read the genome and so
in particular I was working on how on
cell to cell variation so if if if we
measure a bulk population of a million
cells we can get some average amount of
protein per cell that's produced but but
if we look at any one cell one single
cell might have one-tenth of that or ten
times that amount and so how is this
cell to cell variation also encoded in
the DNA what are the sequences the like
sequence features in the DNA that affect
in the amount of South is a variation
okay so then the cell has a constant
query process that it's running to its
mechanistic parts and it's always
knowing what amount of these different
parts of the cell that I have how many
mitochondria I have or how
much ribosomes I have bobble proteins I
have and then so the cell kind of has
like a ledger in a sense and it's
constantly updating it's like ledger and
then there's moments where the the
amount of of proteins in okay fine in a
in a in a large in a large amount of
cells the average will be pretty just
like on in in in the human race the
average will be a specific given average
but when you look at one cell it could
be one-tenth of that average in terms of
the amount of proteins it has versus ten
times the amount of proteins in the
individual ones so just like with maybe
overall on the planet we could have
maybe a specific amount of wealth on the
planet in total in the sum but then one
person could have like three percent of
the total wealth and another person
could have 0.000001 percent of the total
wealth so yeah and wealth is a nice
example right so we don't look at the
mean the average when we think about
wealth because it's so influenced by the
top 0.01% of the population so that
really increases the value of mean
income for example we look at the median
and when we think about wealth of of
countries wealth of people and similarly
in in cells the average can sometimes
not even exist so there are cases where
you have a population of cells that have
lots of some protein a population of
cells that have very little amount of
this protein you take the average that's
in the middle but there are no cells
that are in the middle they only are all
on or all off and so sometimes the
average is completely misleading value
whoa so either they'll have a lot of the
proteins or a little bit of you know
teens but there's not really a lot in
the middle yeah
there's cases like this that exists and
of course if you were to take a
population level average you would get a
value that's in the middle even though
there are no cells like that well okay
okay cool okay and this was the main
project when you were yeah miss Roza
yeah this was the main one do you think
that that ledger analogy is a decent way
to look at it like the cell keeps a
ledger of its parts I think for some
proteins yes it's gonna be a dynamic
ledger the cell is basically gonna be
constantly checking do I have enough of
this do I have too much of this and then
modifying gene expression modifying
other things if something becomes too
much or too little for other things I
think the cell doesn't care so much
there's quite a lot of proteins in the
cell so different proteins one thing we
found in in Israel's that different
proteins have very different amounts of
variability some proteins have lots of
variability other proteins have very
little variability and this amount of
variability is encoded in DNA so
evolution has selected to say okay this
gene I really care how much there's
going to be and I'm going to kind of
keep track of how much there is and very
tightly regulated and when I'm making it
I'm going to make always exactly the
same amount in other proteins whether
you have ten times too much or ten times
too little the cell doesn't really seem
to care so much at least in the
experiments that we can do in lab it may
be that there's some environmental
condition where the cell really does
care or our experiments are not
sensitive enough to pick up this cell
scary but certainly this cell doesn't
care that much so it could even be that
the cell has a ledger of its own
internal mechanistic parts but also its
environment that it's in so it's
constantly dynamically adjusting the
ledger and then expressing genetically
to dynamically adjust yes interesting
this'll definitely cares about the
environment yeah yeah whoa
the ledger internally in the ledger
external kind of like we have one - like
we're like okay my ledger for my stomach
is I haven't eaten yet today you know
but my like ledger for my outside world
is like it's whatever it's like 2:30
p.m. right
and it's a little Sony out you know so
like that's not raining you know which
is so these are like different
environmental lectures so I wouldn't
need to bring an umbrella today you know
so yeah yeah interesting yeah there was
um there was a quote from from when we
were hanging out yesterday where I I
said something along the lines of like
when we were hanging out it was like
like Lucas goes Alan this is how biology
works and then I go well Lucas is it
possible that civilization works in a
similar way and and so it was great when
you were like yeah maybe or maybe not
like that quite like that and so there
was just this constant process of trying
to find relatable analogies or metaphors
or story telling methodologies that
could then get other people around the
world to better understand biology it's
so important to be a good communicator
okay so then how about post Israel how
did you accept this position in
Barcelona to be a PI and a professor
that was five years yeah yeah
so I I went to Barcelona I never been to
her salon before but I liked I lived in
Tel Aviv
during my postdoc I liked this kind of
Mediterranean lifestyle that was a fun
city and I went to our salon on my
office looked out long to the
Mediterranean I went swimming during a
lunch break during my interview and then
I went back to the city for a week or so
to check it out and I said I could live
here and the science is very good also
of course but the city is fantastic yeah
well more your pinching points are like
get the mediterranean the city the life
besides I love that okay and then so
then what did you end up you know
signing on to investigate so when we in
my postdoc we worked on self this aware
of the gene expression and at the end of
my postdoc I guess um we were still
doing experiments on this but I was
we're trying to thank me when I said we
me and
and a friend of mine who's now a
professor at Yale David Van Dyke he was
in the same lab as me work together and
we're done okay
like what is more exciting than gene
expression what is where is their cell
cell variability where is it interesting
but where is their field that people
don't really know so much about because
people know a lot about cells about gene
expressions and worked on for a long
time and so we thought well what about
growth and proliferation so so whether
cell cell division division after
division after division so not so much
the length of time it takes one cell to
divide but the the rate of growth of a
whole population of cells and if we look
at single cells we see that some of them
were proliferating very rapidly and
other cells in the same population that
have the same DNA sequence and are in
the same environment are right next to
each other are growing much more slowly
and so we said okay well there's lots of
cell cell variability there and noise
there let's try and figure out what's
happening
here and we we didn't know anything so
the first thing we did in Barcelona was
we developed some techniques to measure
cell to cell variability and
proliferation and to understand how this
relates to gene expression so we
developed some techniques to get the
slope were fighting cells from a
population and also the fast
proliferating cells from a population
and then we could do RNA sequencing on
these cells and other sorts of
experiments because we were able to grab
the slow and fast proliferating cells
and to physically separate them from
this single population and so this
thought is kind of better and just
generally understand what's going on in
the system and then I spent most of the
rest of the time in Barcelona trying to
understand where this cell cell
variability in growth comes from and
also what are the consequences for the
cells whoa okay in proliferation you
also see great variability some cells
are proliferating quite healthfully and
rapidly and others are much more slowly
and so then it's okay let's take a
single cell from both of those a faster
growing slower growing
sequence the RNA yeah okay and when you
found when he did the RNA sequencing
what were the findings hmm
so we found a couple of things that were
sort of expected and some unexpected
things which i think is always good all
right we know something about biology
and so you should always be able to find
something that you look back on and say
all this makes sense so we found that
fast growing cells need to make more
proteins which totally makes up sense
right if you're if you're growing more
quickly you need to be producing more
cell producing more biomass and so fast
growing cells have more genes for
producing more biomass for producing
more cells slow growing cells seem to be
very stressed they were expressing more
genes different types of genes just kind
of expressing more stuff from their
genome and so seem to be sort of maybe
diversifying themselves a little bit
like and at that point we weren't really
sure whether it was every single cell
becoming diverse or whether our slow
cells or a population of individual
cells and we're still not really sure
eat you it so you've got two
possibilities one possibility is that
every cell is diversified as much as it
possibly can be and the other
possibility is that you've got this
population of slow cells they look
diverse from a population level but at
the individual level you would see that
one cell is doing tasks a another cell
doing test be a third cell doing test C
and you're kind of mixing them all
together
and it looks diverse from there but
certainly that slow growing population
is much more diverse and much more
stressed but also much more stress
resistant than the fast growing
population okay so so so so faster
growing is more stress resistant is the
last
resistance is lower growing is more
stress resistant okay so you're more
vulnerable if you're growing faster yes
you're much more vulnerable if you're
going faster okay and then within the
faster growing you saw that with RNA
sequencing that there was a higher
production of proteins yeah and that was
a pretty given like okay that make sense
yeah
and then you also saw that in
specifically the faster growing or maybe
in maybe it was just in the faster
growing but that you if you if you saw
the whole proliferation the whole
culture that there was a lull of just
the cut though the organism was going in
a specific direction but then when you
went and took individual cells out you
could maybe see that there was like a
Type A or a tiny execution process it
was focused on yeah especially for the
slow growing population especially in
the slow growing yeah
population we think that in the fast
population there's less diversity the
cells are probably just kind of
maximizing their growth rate there's one
major way to do that and all the cells
are growing as fast as they possibly can
to do this and the slow growing
population we see that there's more
different types of cells there are kind
of different types of slow growing cells
and some of these are resistant to to
heat for example but where some of them
are resistant to drugs to antifungal
drugs but they're sensitive to heat and
so maybe that so there's this idea of
bet hedging that there's that the
population as a whole wants to grow very
fast it does this by having individual
cells that are growing very fast but if
some stress comes along it will kill the
fast-growing cells because they're very
sensitive to to stress they're very easy
to kill and then the slow growing cells
you can imagine two strategies one would
be to have some slow growing cells that
are reasons
into everything that could come along
but maybe this is difficult or
impossible the by the way the cells are
wired and so what we will we see is that
there's different types of slow cells
and some of them will be resistant to
some things and uh and others resistant
to other things and the the thought is
that these if something comes along and
it kills all of the non resistant cells
all the fast cells then the slow cells
can repopulate that population whereas
if you had no slow cells the population
as a whole would be able to grow a
little tiny bit faster in the absence of
any bad things happening the absence of
stress but if some stress come went
along it would kill off the whole
population it would kill off everyone
and then you have zero cells and now
your evolutionarily dead undead and yeah
this one was really interesting when we
were diving into it yesterday this idea
of bet hedging and this is quite a bit
of what you're doing now at the terry
lab yeah analysis of this proliferation
and bet hedging and you know a single
cell or any sequencing stuff like that
yeah okay and so you were doing quite a
bit of this in Barcelona yeah then okay
cool cool
okay so all right so in the the slower
growing population the let's let's
actually go to the faster growing
population is more vulnerable to to to
death from some sort of an environmental
stimuli like maybe that a drug like an
antibiotic meanwhile that's trying to
grow in our um the bacteria is trying to
grow in our in our body and so then it's
more vulnerable because it's
proliferating faster and faster and it
may not have the hedged bets placed on
some of its even a very small population
within it that is able to be
antibiotic-resistant yeah whereas it may
be the small population there's that
that there has been a bet that's been
your doing some bet hedging in the
smaller population where there are at
least as percentage of the cells that
are expressing themselves in a way that
is not quick proliferation but is at
least saying we're gonna be a drug
resistance so that we can make sure that
we evolutionary stay alive longer yeah
gosh that part is so nuts okay and then
now let's go back to that first part so
in the small population you see more
like type a Type B type C type D like
yeah and maybe in a sense we could
compare this to like how someone is
right now like like literally bringing
watermelons onto campus at PKU and then
like and then they're like you know
cutting the watermelons and giving it to
the students that are paying for it and
stuff mmm that's like type A and type B
is like a pie okay but like this is in
the population of the planet like humans
okay
so then one node is growing watermelon
and selling watermelon two students one
note is doing some cutting-edge
biological research so at different
nodes cell types are expressing
themselves in different ways there's
like thousands of PI's across the plant
and there's like tens of thousands or
hundreds of thousands of farmers around
the planet there's maybe a little bit
more of the type of cell that is a
farmer than there is a PI cell type to
think more about this these like
sociological comparisons are so
interesting i we talked a little bit
about as this comparison with like a
investment portfolio this is a good one
yeah the hedging is for hedging yeah
that you
there's the simplest thing would be to
invest in
you know index fun tracking S&P or
something like this and this will do
reasonably well but in an economic
downturn you're screwed and so maybe you
want to put aside a little bit of money
into a into something that's counter
cyclical that will that will you know
that won't well you won't lose all your
funding if the economy crashes and there
are many different things that won't
lose all their money if the economy
crashed just so you could put a little
bit into shorting the housing market and
a little bit into some bonds and Japan
or something like this that's relatively
stable and so none of these will grow as
fast but they won't lose all their value
mmm in the case of a disaster mm-hmm
yeah this diversified portfolio analogy
is really interesting everyone and their
mother is pouring money into real estate
mm-hmm and that's like the fast
proliferating and then all these other
types are then maybe in the slower
proliferation are bonds or the different
types of slower growth diversify aspects
of the portfolio so that if there's a
big economic downturn for real estate
that you don't just go to zero so you
have bet hedging being done even in
cells in cell populations there's a bet
hedging being done so the other
alternative and there's not really good
evidence for one or the other is that
cells simply can't all grow this fast
and they're growing as fast as they
possibly can and they're growing so fast
that they have some chance of you know
tripping and falling like if you were
running hurdles as fast as you could and
there are these some thresholds where
you might gain a little bit of speed but
you increase the chance of you tripping
over a hurdle like increase the chance
of a poor mutation may be either
mutation or something going wrong
biochemically like building up too much
of of something cause some component
inside so that becomes toxic because you
don't have the ability to get rid of it
fast enough or we're not really sure
yeah but this is we also have and that's
called a tofu G when it the cell gets
rid of
component that yes yeah yeah yeah so you
could do you could grow so fast like a
like a hurdler that's running that they
trip over the hurdle like a cell would
be proliferating so fast that some
biochemistry goes wrong and it's a top a
topological process other it's an
autopsy process ends up failing yeah and
then there's a moment and yeah yeah and
now we're going slow yeah and so this is
sort of the evolutionary neutral point
of view this hasn't in this point of
view this slow growing state has not
evolved to be such it just is a
consequence of this all trying to grow
as fast as it possibly can and it could
be both of the things that you described
yeah okay interesting okay and those two
things again are adjusting if you're
growing too fast if I okay I like the
hurdling analogy so it's like you you
could be growing too fast and you could
trip so you want to prevent that that
could be one of the these quantitative
mechanistic biological components of
cell proliferation um is hedging against
that and then it and then the other one
is that you want to diversify this
portfolio for all different types of
environmental potential malevolence and
yeah interesting and you could imagine a
situation like where it only matters if
you get gold silver or bronze and so you
want to run as fast as you can because
coming in fourth versus tripping and
coming in last are the same Wow
okay okay
Wow yeah if that's the if that's the
case then that adds a whole new layer of
complexity if only first at third place
matter and fourth is the same as
tripping and falling and placing zero
there last because then you would want
to put as much of your logic towards
quantitatively proliferating putting the
mechanisms for proliferation prioritize
that you've put the foot on as much of
the gas as possible yeah because we want
for a second or third yeah it's kind of
in a sense it's maybe it's somewhat
similar it's someone different and are
like like in our sociological
hierarchies because we in in the sense
of in the entire eight billion hierarchy
let's say of wealth that if you come in
fourth you're still doing ridiculously
well so you might want to just put your
foot on the gas but but yeah play some
you might have some bets and stuff but
if you're maybe if you're only in a
group of like like like 10 P is in in a
in a in a life sciences department at a
university then you know place and forth
isn't so much on the grid it didn't land
so like placing fourth it's like okay
well they're the fourth best P I out of
10 add like the life sciences you know
department so versus being fourth and
like this whole the wealth hierarchy
interesting
there's always trying to find these
sociological analogies okay
and then I'm gonna go out thinking about
this if it's somewhat similar to the way
that the tech industry is working now
where you burn through insane amounts of
cash to become first in your market
that's right and it doesn't matter if
you're there's no difference between
zeroth place and you know the fourth
biggest you know econ
platform in a market nobody's buying
from them everyone's buying from Alibaba
and Amazon no one even knows who was the
second post like eBay you know do you
definitely don't know the third yeah
yeah yeah interesting and you don't know
the third rideshare company either you
know dee dee in China and you know BER
and lyft in the US yeah another places
in the world but that's it yeah so we
only remember one two and maybe the
three maybe so forth is almost the same
then in the Sun says Wow so that's why
it's poor as many resources on to the
fire of the tech company's growth as
possible yeah what an interesting
analogy so we have some some of our
economical processes that some of our
quantitative mechanistic biological
processes related to economical growth
are actually somewhat similar to the way
that cells proliferate I think that's
fair to say you get the same sort of
exponential benefits so if if two
populations are growing exponentially so
the bigger they are the faster they
increase then a very small difference in
initial growth rates gives you very
large constant you know advantage
towards the end and this is why tech
companies blow through all this money to
become first in their market is because
of the thought is that once they have
kind of this dominant dominant place
this gives them advantages that are not
available to second third fourth place
okay so when you were teaching you about
this you were saying it from the
perspective of the the predictability of
evolution and at least to have a better
version of understanding and making that
more
to tative so what exactly can we say
about the like predicting the the fates
of single cells and of organisms and
like why are you so passionate about
understanding the codified processes of
that all right so we I use predict
because if I say if I told you I
understood something you would basically
just have to take my word for it but if
I tell you I can predict something I can
write down my prediction and you can
test me on that and you can say okay can
you predict this and so biologists want
to understand things they want to
understand how cells work they want to
understand why we look and behave the
way they do and we want to understand
things do but we want to do so in in a
quantitative manner that I can write
down my predictions for the future
and see if they come true or not and so
I I want to if I have a population of a
million cells and I give them some drug
that kills 99% of them I want to be able
to tell you before giving them the drug
which cells will survive in which cells
will die if if we can do that then we
can really understand the system and
there might be some complete randomness
in this factor so I might be able to
tell you this cell has a 90% chance of
survival and this cell has a 10% chance
of survival that might be the best I can
do if I knew all information but we're
now very far from being able to do that
and so this is what we're really
interested in doing can we can we
predict which cells will survive a drug
treatment can we predict which cancer
cells will survive chemotherapy this
sort of thing and then can we predict we
know that in in hospital settings for
example cells tend to evolve antibiotic
resistance very quickly also inside of
patients cells tend to evolve antibiotic
resistance and especially antifungal
resistance pathogenic fungi evolve
antifungal resistance cancer cells
evolve chemotherapy resistance very
reproducibly but sometimes they don't
and in the lab we can do experiments and
we see that some types of cells are able
to evolve this drug resistance very
rapidly and very reproduce
another cells just don't or do so much
more slowly and so this cell tells us
that evolution should be predictable
that we should be able to predict kind
of which cells are more easy to evolve
than other cells and that this
information is somehow encoded in the
cell and probably encoded in DNA as I
see I don't want to say I see with
specially with the oncological the
benefits here of doing your experiments
in the lab is that so many of us have
parents or grandparents that are
literally going through processes of
cancer and de teat their health
deteriorating from that and if we can do
this science faster we can understand
and more effectively build better tools
for it we can understand then there are
specific genetics encoded within
cancerous cells that enable them to
fight better our treatments than other
ones that just seem to die off from our
from our treatments so we want to now
what would we do that would be optimal
would we want to figure out how to
compete against the the the the
cancerous cells that have a stronger
robustness towards fighting against our
treatments so it's a good question so
one one thing we've thought about doing
with the bacteria is are there non-toxic
things you could give the cells that
would interfere with their ability to
evolve or would interfere with their
ability to be in this resistant state so
these are the kind of non-obvious
treatments that you wouldn't normally
you think okay well maybe if I give two
different drugs then that'll kill this
O's better indeed that that usually does
work but cells could evolve resistance
to this also but but if we could put
this del cell in the state where it was
less evolvable or or we could put the
population of cells into a state where
there are fewer
these resistant cells and that might
even be making by making them grow
faster right because as I said Kent
cells that are growing fast are more
sensitive to stresses into drugs and so
if we could get rid of the non growing
tumor cells by making more money making
them grow and of course this would be
very risky but if we could make all of
the cancer cells grow then all the
cancer cells could be killed by
chemotherapy a one-two punch of sorts
where you give them this little
artificial boost then you make them
think AHA we got it and then you come in
with the second hit and you're like a
high you thought because you were
growing proliferating faster you became
more sensitive vulnerable and now we
really wiped you out exactly so you move
you move them from slow proliferation
State to a fast proliferation State and
then you wipe them out you trick them
that's one option okay and then the
other option for this this evolution of
drug resistance here you get this how's
the drug and it kills most of the cells
but some of the cells have some
mutations and they're able to gain more
mutations and evolve drug resistance
if we you can only give a and right now
we don't know you know if we have a
choice of a couple of different
treatments for a tumor for an infection
we give one that the cells are sensitive
to and end of story and we hope that it
kills all the cells if we could predict
hey this infection is going to evolve
resistance to drug a but it's not going
to evolve resistance to drug B if we
could predict evolution and if these
evolutionary paths were different enough
then we could give treatment based on
the predicted future of the infection or
of the cancer instead of just based on
the current state
as in there is a you could map the
cancers future trajectory and then give
treatment based on where it's going yeah
instead its current sagal so if you
think about climate change we're not
worried about climate change because of
this 1 degree temperature rise Lloyd
because of the future predictions of
climate change it's were quite confident
in and we're less interested in telling
people to burn less fossil fuels were
more interested in being like let's
obsolete all of the old technology with
this new more efficient more effective
cleaner more sustainable technology but
all this is based on predictions of the
future and not so much what is the
current state of the earth yeah so we as
future prediction machines are thinking
about our grandkids and the planet that
they inherit hmm and that's why we're
caring so much and there's actually an
indigenous principle called the seventh
generation principle so mmm literally
them thinking prior to acting anything
okay how is this gonna affect seven
generations out prediction is hard that
foreign advance but I think it's also
then you're right it is very hard that
foreign advance but it also can teach us
something with it's not just I'm gonna
fish here or I'm gonna harvest this or
I'm gonna burn this fossil fuel because
it is not that's a very immediate we
it's like overly reliant on immediacy
and we've developed a cortex that
enables us to do something like think
about a seventh generation and be like
if I fish here what happens in next
generation if I harvest this what
happens next generation how do i
replenish this
replenish the fishery or produce a more
sustainable way of producing energy for
my down yeah mm-hmm interesting so then
the ledger the dynamic ledger of a
cancer cell is also understanding its
internal processes understanding its
exterior environments and also trying to
predict some sort of future where it can
basically take over that organism
potentially oh this is hard stuff yeah
so there's a big open question and in
biology of like can cells evolve evolve
ability can you can a cell have selected
for the ability to change in the future
I'm tempted to say no consult evolve
evolve ability yeah because right so for
a cancer cell its current state is okay
I need to grow as fast as I can or for a
pup for population for any organism it
wants to grow as much as it can
maybe we're calling it complicated
enough to realize that well if I grow as
fast as I possibly can then my
grandchildren are screwed but microbes
are not certainly or we would at least
think that maybe maybe they are and
that's why they do this bad who knows
but now you're asking can they can to
cell have evolved so that it can more
easily change its genome in the future
in response to something or to allow it
to grow in some new environment and that
I'm hesitant to say that
I'm just gonna do that yeah interesting
we can certainly design them to be like
that yeah this is this like designer
organism idea could we make the
proliferation populations more
prediction machines about the future
more evolvable to have them develop
evolvability more mm-hmm
this may be that and maybe that has to
do with a running so many different
engineering so many different
simulations of the proliferation for
them to build more resistance to all of
the different environmental stimuli so
we throw at them and then they encode
those better and better yeah huh Wow
yeah this is really biotechnology which
and as we become designers of the
biology as a whole new opening up of
potentials what about you give us the
oncological assistance this work in the
lab can help with that where else these
things have worked in the lab can help
with so with infectious diseases which I
would sort of put in the same category
as cancer in the sense that we do some
treatments so you have fungi that in
fact rice and wheat and things like this
and you give them at you spray
antifungals onto the fields and they
just become resistant attempting viruses
that are killing some crops so all these
sort of fall into this general class of
single cells that are growing kind of as
fast as they can and they're trying to
grow and we're trying to kill them well
and then what would a farmer
do for a crop rice we that is currently
has the solution of just spraying
antifungal but then obviously they
develop the the cup of the counter
properties that counter that antifungal
spray so how would your lab produce the
solution hmm so so here I think that if
we could predict which strains which
pathogenic strains which can will evolve
resistance to which drugs we could say
okay spray a fungicide a but not
fungicide B because this particular
genotype will evolve resistance to a
more much more easily than resistance to
be even though the initial killing will
be the same the evolutionary kind of
paths will be different this I think
would be really cool to be able to do
and is there an even more maybe golden
key solution to it where there could be
a process of engineering the genomes of
the rice or the wheat to be just
SuperDuper combative to all of the
different of fungicides yeah this is
this is sort of how the BT from Monsanto
works for BT corn BT soy if you have
crops that express their own toxins
these end up being much more effective
if I spray fungicide on the field I'm
spraying the workers on that field I'm
spraying the soil I'm spraying the air
and I'm spraying the rivers around it
but if the crops produce that toxin it's
much more targeted to the fungi that are
growing on the toxin and you can have
the crops produce very toxic things so
plants are nice and that they're not
human right so things that are very
toxic to plants and very toxic to to
plant pathogens can be completely
non-toxic to mammals
and we would just had need to have some
sort of like launched in little tests of
like is it really non-toxic yeah yeah so
if we engineer the rice or engineer the
corner we that to compete combat against
the that infectious toxins more than
would to compete thinking could and also
to combat against pesticides and against
drought and all those types of things or
maybe just make them grow in different
conditions so some all sub stuff the
question would be then if I eat that for
20 years am I so good mmm-hmm
and we would just need to do the
longitudinal test to do so yeah okay
okay and then let's talk about how like
overall this field as exponential
technology continues to increase and our
computational capacity continues to
increase our microscopy increases all
these types of things are kind of like
coming together sequencing abilities all
these types of things coming together do
you see us unlocking some sort of basic
source code of cells and biology in
general I think we're getting much
better so we have the source code we
have the genomes thud see that's the
easy part
it's reading the source code you know
the source code is all assembly from I
don't know an old IBM mainframe or
something like that it's very difficult
to read its source code that has been
worked on by programmers over the past
many hundreds of millions of years so
it's a complete mess there's no comments
anywhere no comments so we're getting
much better reading it that's for sure
there's no repositories of like the
older Bill exactly we can go back well
we can go back 10,000 years right we can
get resurrect into DNA from about 10,000
years ago but that doesn't do it's
nearly good enough right we
yeah okay so source code is there with
the DNA yeah okay
and then it's specific short sequences
of DNA create amino acids with amino
acids which then create proteins and so
that part which we're still figuring out
as well which sequences create which
amino acids create which that wins got
it's more all of it do any much yeah and
how many total proteins are made by like
are 25,000 25,000 depends on what you
count between 4,000 and we have that all
down yeah the question is how does the
cell control and how's our body control
these so how does the cell tell cell
tele cells to become high cells and to
become no cells and this sort of thing
and how does it cell know how much you
know how much melatonin to produce to
create a pigment or how much hair to
produce or whatever so these kind of
quantitative things of how much of this
gene how should I make how much of this
protein should I make that we're still
working on yeah melanin fur yes our skin
tone and melatonin for sleepiness and
and then
digestion too like if you you know how
do you you know when the cell regulates
to produce digestion abilities when you
eat food and yeah that type of stuff
it's like yeah the pigment of the color
your eyes blah blah blah there's so many
things why is there no hair on your
forehead no so all this is encoded in
DNA and this we have no idea so
somewhere in that DNA is the statement
no hair on foreheads yes for most people
yes sometimes that goes wrong and you do
get hair on foreheads yeah but we have
no idea where that information is in the
deal okay source code how that produces
amino acids and proteins got it how the
cell decides when to call forth that
building block of amino acid to gene
expression amino acid to protein is like
hmm
figuring out yeah okay okay okay and
then do you then think that it's
possible for us to figure out how the
cell keeps that dynamic ledger of its
internal state of its external state of
it's like future possibilities I do I
think that we can do this in simple cell
systems we can do this in engineered
systems that we've so if we take a
system and we design it and then we make
changes we're pretty good now at
predicting the outcomes of those changes
if we take one thing that we do in my
group is we will design for example a
million different variants of a single
protein and then use all that data to to
understand what is the effect and to
predict what is the effect of individual
mutations and of groups of mutations on
function so once we have a million data
points if I make a new mutation the
million first data point I can use those
previous million to predict pretty well
what the outcome of that new mutation is
going to be even though I haven't
measured it yet and I think eventually
we'll get there with humans I think it
will take much longer humans are
complicated but right the ultimate goal
is if I should be able to take a new
patient and say ok this patient has the
following thousand mutations in them
relative to the population as a whole
what is the impact of each of these
mutations on their health and we're
moving there slowly I'm confident that
we'll get there yes yeah ok given the
rapid pace of exponential technology and
democratization of the tools and our
ability to probe with science that we
think that we could basically have a
better understanding of the ledger of
biology and all of the quantitative
mechanisms of biology to the point where
it could be that when you come in for
you don't even need to come in you just
have a constant stream of your
biometrics being processed and that you
can and that's literally being pattern
recognition on that compared to our vast
library of other patterns that have been
recognized and it's just like okay Lucas
you're weird sorry I needed to detect a
specific pattern with your biometrics
where it's going to be important for you
to get eight hours of sleep tonight or
to go exercise or to eat a healthier
meal or whatever to make sure you don't
have some sort of dysfunctional
pathology that develops or not okay okay
yes whoa okay it also has been
hypothesized that this is like a 100
trillion dollar industry over the next
like hundred years that biotech and all
of its components because you were
giving the examples in healthcare but
then there's examples in agriculture and
the examples in energy and there's just
like that's already extremely insanely
massive fields and given the amounts of
big data they're being crunched by
computation and all this stuff like
they're gonna be some serious big
booming companies and like get creating
in that space that's a big space get
researching in that space forming comes
mixes yeah yeah oh yeah a couple quick
questions on the way out
how can we inspire more people around
our world to work together I think
making it easier to work together
scientists arts and they want to
collaborate and also I think many
scientists enjoy traveling to different
places and sort of using collaboration
as an excuse to go on vacation and check
out new cultures new places but I I
think regulations tend to make it hard
right you weren't able to you know you
use the awesome payment systems that we
have access to in China because you
don't have a national ID number and your
numbered bank account and likewise their
issues and similar issues when people
visit the US yeah
so this I think makes it more difficult
yeah it's just increasing mobility yeah
doesn't I'm using appropriate mobility
but just leaving temporary temporary
mobility and making it easier for PhD
students who go to the u.s. to go home
to visit their families yeah yeah I'm
making it easier for PhD students who
want to come to China it's really
difficult for foreign PhD students to
come to China you say degrees of freedom
degrees of mobility even if temporary
just making it so that you can vet
people and through a trusted process
more effectively and get increased
global collaboration and creativity
through that going into this exponential
technology age you have a young son as
well what do you think young kids should
do should learn that's a skill that's
gonna just be enabling them to be
equipped really well I think just
general problem-solving I was kind of in
an abstract sense like I if you if you
know how to solve abstract problems that
have undefined solutions where it's not
clear how to solve this then you can
learn programming if you need to you can
learn to interface with politicians if
you need to you can kind of learn all
the specific things later but if all
you've done throughout your life is
solve problems that have defined steps
to ending up at a predetermined solution
where you already maybe know the answer
then you're in trouble once you get to
the first task where there is no clear
answer or it's not clear how to get
there and I see this as a problem in in
my education and in the education system
here
I remember in our labs and physics and
undergraduate we're solving all these
problems and doing these experiments
where we know the answer already we're
measuring G the gravitational constant
but we already know that the answer and
we know how the experiment worked out
and I don't think that these are
inspiring and I also don't think that
they teach you to do
problem-solving yeah yeah here the 17
sustainable development goals figure out
how to solve exactly yeah stuff like
that I love that you know
okay how about what is the ultimate
nature of this reality why are we here
what is the meaning of this the
teleology of the species I don't think
there's any inherent meaning for being
here I don't think we're here for some
purpose yeah it's interesting seeing how
many people use this question from like
a very like materialistic perspective
versus like a lot of other people are
like hyper spiritual and like magical
about it and it's like interesting to
find out where those two perspectives
yeah yeah consciousness you think what
do you think is a biological phenomenon
or what are your thoughts about here I'm
purely materialistic about that - yeah
what about I just think we figured out
some things about it's hard to figure
out it's hard to study we don't have a
good model system for studying
consciousness we can't do experiments on
people other organisms don't have the
same consciousness as we do if you know
like the Thomas Nagel essay what is it
like to be a bat mm-hmm like I have no
idea what it's like to be a three year
old toddler even though I live with one
like even though you lived as one yeah
yeah so without a good system for really
understand and and in spite of that fact
we've done we know more about
consciousness and how kind of emotional
states are encoded in in
neurotransmitter concentrations and
thing like this and we did 100 years ago
and I think that this whole content
increase what do you think is the role
of love I think you got to love what
you're doing you got to love who you're
doing it with yeah
yeah do you think this is a simulation
no but I don't care so much so long as
it's a so long as the programmer is not
changing the parameters of the
simulation while it's running because
that would be doing science very
difficult idea what do you think the
most beautiful thing in the world when
you find something that nobody else in
the world knows oh that's that's
exciting and you very quickly forget
that nobody else in the world knows this
and I think even before you get to
publish a paper on or something I find
that I do it in certainly my students do
it we forget how cool this is because
we've already known it for six months or
a year or whatever
but nobody else in the world knows this
and this is completely new yeah I love
that answer it's such a good one I
believe that's the first time we've had
that one on the show oh yeah yeah yeah
that's a huge one discover what no one
else knows and then bring that forth as
a gift into the world I love that okay
Wow
thank you so much for fun thank you
thinking it's been an honor and a
pleasure it's great hanging out with you
yesterday and today a lot of fun
thank you good I'm really happy to hear
that it's been so enlightening thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
have more conversations to your friends
families co-workers people online on
social media about quantitative
mechanistic prediction in biology have
more conversation about that how can our
meant our health augment our society at
large and go and build the new tools
that help us poke and probe at that and
check out the links in the bio below
that the carry lab also check out
Lucas's Twitter profile as well check
those links out support the artists the
entrepreneurs the leaders in your
communities and around the world that
you believe in support simulation i
links are below to you and cool things
like coming at china for interviews and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you for tuning in and
see you soon peace that's a rather good
job
[Music]